-Our first guest tonight i
an Academy Award-winning actor
you know from films such
as "Interstellar"
and "Manchester by the Sea."
He's currently starring
in "Our Friend,"
which is in theaters
and On Demand now,
and both stars in and produced
"The World to Come,"
in theaters this Friday,
and On Demand March 2nd.
Please welcome back to the sho
Casey Affleck.
How are you, Casey?
-Hey, buddy!
How are you?
-I'm doing well.
It's very nice to see you.
You know, I know you used
to live in New York
and, obviously,
you grew up in the Northeast
We're getting a lot of snowy
weather, these days.
Do you miss it?
Be honest.
-Oh, man. I miss it.
I crave it.
I hate hearing about how muc
snow you guys are getting.
I really hate hearing
you guys complain about it
It makes me jealous.
As you know, in L.A.,
it's the same every single day
-Yeah. See, you know,
obviously, I grew up
in New Hampshire.
I don't mind some slushy snow.
I mean, the only thing
about New York
that's the downside
is it's only beautiful
for about 15 minutes
before it turns like gray.
-I appreciate it more
than you do.
-[ Laughs ] So even love
-I appreciate it
-the gray snow.
-for like 20 minutes.
[ Laughter ]
This is what you want.
You want something
that looks like this.
-Yeah. So that's where
you are right now.
That's your life in L.A.
See, that's so depressing to me.
That's my backyard, dude.
[ Laughter ]
It's really beautiful, buddy
-Thank you.
Thank you.
-Oh, great.
This is a nice tie-in
to your science fiction work
[ Laughter ]
-Is that really Fred Armisen
on the drums, there?
-That's really Fred Armise
on the drums.
By the way, like I usually
would say, "Hey, you know,
stop goofing around
with the Zoom backgrounds.
You have the most
busted background
of anybody who's been
on our show.
[ Laughter ]
Where are you doing this,
in an abandoned school?
[ Laughter ]
-It's the only room I got.
It's the room in my house
where the computer is
and I had a bunch of thing
pinned up there,
but it just felt too personal.
So, how's that?
-There you go.
I feel like
that's the Casey I know.
[ Laughter ]
Hey, I mentioned
your New England roots.
How was the Super Bowl for you
You know, we had Bill Burr
on yesterday
and I really feel like
this is a week
of Massachusetts royalty
and I asked him what it felt
like to watch Tom Brady.
How was it for you?
-It was amazing.
-Yeah?
-I loved it.
I mean, I don't know anyon
who's not rooting for Tom.
The great thing about
Massachusetts sports fans is
they aren't bitter.
[ Laughter ]
They're just good sports.
And, you know,
it was time for Tom to go.
Here's a few things
I'll say about Tom.
He's played in 10 Super Bowls,
so everyone thinks that he's
just always been the greatest,
but he lost a lot.
He wasn't always the greates
and that makes him even greater,
because he just keeps going.
And the other thing is that,
you know,
Tom is smart enough to kno
you can't win alone, you know.
The team with the best players
doesn't win the game.
The players with the best team
wins the game.
Tom brought,
he got Leonard Fournette
and Ronald Jones
and Chris Godwin.
Those guys won
the Super Bowl, too.
So everyone's talking about Tom.
That was a strong team
and they played a great game
So, super, super happy for him
-Are you friendly
with Tom Brady?
-In my mind.
[ Laughter ]
-Thank you for your honesty.
-Like he didn't call me
after the game,
if that's what you mean.
-You a couple of movies
out right now.
"Our Friend" is a film
that actually was based
on an Esquire article,
a very moving Esquire article,
but not one that you'd rea
and would think,
right off the bat,
it would be easy to adapt.
-No. It was it's it was writte
by a guy named Matt Teague
and he was a journalist
and he wrote an article
about his wife
struggling with cancer,
and their two kids.
And then that article
was turned into a screenplay
and the screenplay
was turned into a movie.
The article is a little bi
of a kind of
warts-and-all depiction
of what it was like,
a heartbreaking,
very sad account,
and the movie,
made by Gabriela Cowperthwaite
is not really like that.
It focuses a lot
on a friend of theirs
who came to help them
during all of that,
and that's played
by Jason Segel
and he sort of drops
everything in his life
and he comes and shows up
for this family,
moves in with them
and helps take care of them.
It's got Denée Benton
and Marielle Scott
and Jake Owen, Dakota Johnson,
Jason Segel.
And it's really funny also
and kind of fun
and sort of heartwarming.
-Very moving as well,
and that's true
of the other film you have
right now, "The World to Come.
This is a film you produce
as well as star in,
and it takes place in New York
in the 1850s.
You guys shot it in Romania.
How was that?
-It was pretty cool.
We were in Transylvania,
which is like a part of Romania,
that, you know,
where you'll remember
that Dracula came from.
We were shooting right by th
kind of "Dracula's castle"
there.
Dracula wasn't a real person
of course, but,
[ Laughter ]
they have a castle.
-It's like
the Walt Disney Castle.
Well, I guess Walt Disney'
a real guy,
so it isn't like that.
Never mind.
[ Laughter ]
-Walt is real.
Was real.
And, Dracula,
the legend of Dracula,
is loosely based on somebody
but that wasn't even the castl
that he lived in.
But it is an old castle,
so it's kind of cool to se
and the whole area
is pretty cool
and it was a fun place to shoot.
-Did you go inside the castle?
Is it a castle
you can go inside of?
-You know --
Yeah, you can go inside of it.
I drove out there
one day after work
and I got there right
as they were closing,
-[ Laughs ]
-so I didn't get to go in.
But I stood outside and it
looked pretty creepy
and it says
"Dracula's Castle" on it.
You know.
[ Laughter ]
-I mean, I feel like
we haven't given them
a quote they're going
to use on the poster.
[ Laughter ]
Hey, a lot of people have used
this quarantine time
to improve their skills.
So you were not -- true story --
you were not a golfer
before this time, at all?
-A golfer?
No. I have golfed before.
I didn't pick up any skill
during this time.
I know other people have.
I just could just --
It was all I could do to jus
sort of get through the days
and stay afloat.
I don't know.
That sounds weird,
but I couldn't --
I wasn't like real focused
and picking up a bunch
and, you know, learning
an instrument and stuff.
But I have golfed.
-You posted on Instagram
your golf swing.
Maybe we could take
a look at it real quick
and just show people what
a commitment to a craft
can do for you?
-[ Laughing ]
-[ Laughing ] Here's 00
-Sure.
So this is super slow-mo.
That's not that bad.
-That's slow-no.
It didn't look that bad, there
You know --
Yeah, I'm not a golfer.
That's true. But it's one
of the things you can do
to get outside and play sports
and be apart from people.
I got pretty upset
with that swing right there.
[ Laughter ]
-So we sort of edited,
I feel like,
before your club
took the worst of it.
-[ Laughs ]
Golf, you know, golf is you're
playing against yourself, so
I don't know what that say
about my swing there.
It's a sport you play
against yourself.
I guess I was losing to myself
-[ Laughs ]
Well, it is always
wonderful to see you.
Congrats on both films.
I really do hope, next time,
it's in person.
Thanks for being here.
-Thanks for having me, man
It's nice to see you, too.